>>> TIME NOW YOUR THE
RIDICU-LIST.
FOR THE PAST FEW DAYS WE'VE BEEN
PAYING TRIBUTE TO THE ONE AND
ONLY DAVID LETTERMAN.
LAST NIGHT WAS HIS LAST SHOW.
IF YOU COULDN'T STAY UP THAT
LATE YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN CLIPS
TODAY.
IT WAS AMAZING.
YOU MIGHT HAVE MISSED WHAT WAS
PROBABLY THE COOLEST TRIBUTE TO
DAVE'S RETIREMENT.
CONAN O'BRIEN'S SHOW STARTS AT
11:00 SO IT'S ALREADY ON WHEN
LETTERMAN STARTS.
WATCH WHAT CONAN DID LAST NIGHT.
>> OKAY, IT'S NOW 11:35.
OH, RECORD US BUT SWITCH TO
DAVE.
BYE!
GO, GO.
BUT HIT RECORD.
JUST TODAY.
>> SEE, THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE ME TELLING
YOU TO STOP WATCHING US RIGHT
NOW AND SWITCH OVER TO BILL
O'REILLY.
I'M CONFIDENT I PROBABLY WOULD
NOT DO THAT.
WITH ANYTHING, I'D SWITCH OVER
TO UNIVISION TO WATCH AMARA
CONTROMPA.
ANYBODY?
YOU'RE GOING TO LET ME HANG
HERE, AREN'T YOU?
>> YES FWP.
>> IT'S A SPANISH LANGUAGE SOAP
OPERA.
NOT SHOE THERE'S A LOT OF
AUDIENCE CROSSOVER THOUGH I'VE
OFTEN THOUGHT OUR SHOW HAS THE
SAME KIND OF DRAMA AND
EXCITEMENT.
IS THAT REALLY ON OPPOSITE OF
US?
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
IS IT REALLY?
WOW.
IT IS.
OKAY.
WHAT IS IT CALLED?
THERE YOU GO.
YOU WU YOU WERE WATCHING CONAN
SWITCHED OVER TO LETTERMAN YOU
MISSED WHAT WAS NEXT.
>> THEY'RE GONE NOW.
NOW WE CAN DO WHATEVER THE
[ BLEEP ] WE WANT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> OH, DAVE, WHAT A LEGACY.
WHAT A LEGACY, DAVE.
LOOK WHAT YOU'VE INSPIRED.
THANKS FOR THE INSPIRATION.
>> ANYWAY, GETTING BACK TO ME,
I'VE BEEN ON CONAN'S SHOW.
HE'S UNPREDICTABLE.
THAT WE KNOW.
YEARS AGO WHEN MY BOOK CAME OUT,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" NUMBER ONE
BESTSELLER.
WAS I SAYING THAT?
I THINK THAT EVERY TIME I
MENTION MY BOOK.
HE DID SOMETHING WHEN WE SPOKE
RECENTLY.
DURING THE INTERVIEW, YOU WON'T
REMEMBER THIS.
>> I DO REMEMBER THIS.
>> DURING THE INTERVIEW YOU TOOK
A DRINK AND PUT IT DOWN ON MY
BOOK.
>> YEAH.
>> I JUST REMEMBER --
>> IT WAS GREAT BECAUSE SOMEONE
ELSE MIGHT NOT HAVE SAID
SOMETHING.
YOU ACTUALLY WERE KIND OF --
>> I STOPPED THE WHOLE THING.
>> YOU STOPPED THE WHOLE THING.
I WAS USING HIS BOOK HE WAS
PROMOTING AS A COASTER.
>> I WAS LIKE, I SPENT A YEAR
AND A HALF WRITING THAT THING.
YOU'RE FREAKING PUTTING A DRINK
ON IT.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
I THINK I ENDED UP THROWING IT
OUT THE WINDOW.
>> YES, YOU DID.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT YOER U'RE GG
TO GET WITH THAT